Rohith muhammad al kanoon arriving in
Canada as a refugee after a dramatic
week the 18 year old triumphantly
tweeting I did it from her plane seat as
she made the journey to North America
[Music]
and a half want to Canadians to see that
she's arrived just days earlier the
young Saudi citizen made headlines
around the world
when she attempted to flee what she
called an abusive family that wanted to
force her into an arranged marriage
she'd run away from them while they were
visiting Kuwait fleeing eventually to
Bangkok in Thailand after immigration
officials there threatened to deport her
she barricaded herself into an airport
hotel and tweeted about her situation
until the UN refugee agency noticed I'm
still in the room I have no choice they
said I have to go tomorrow and no one
can help me right now the decision to
offer asylum could heap further pressure
on a relationship already strained by
Canada's previous expressions of support
for women's rights activists and now
there is increased scrutiny on why even
after the murder of Saudi citizen and
us-based journalist Jamel khashoggi
other Western countries can seem
reluctant to take on an influential
regional power led by charismatic Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman the UK
government for example caught up in the
throes of brexit anxiety very concerned
with maintaining positive relations with
the Saudis the Americans of course the
Trump administration still supportive of
Mohammed bin Salman in the wake of the
Jamaat heavy killing this reflects that
the Saudis still have a fair amount of
clout but for the moment were half
Mohammed Al kanoon has a new home a
place where she is safer despite the
impact on diplomacy and global politics
ali-tomás pita Sky News in New York